طلعه جويه جديده مع طلوع كل شمس
مبكرا يبدا سلاح المروحيات الاوكراني
تنفيذ هجماته
في اخطر جبهات الحرب
هذه اللقطات التي وثقناها عبر تثبيت
كاميرات على جسم الطائره بموافقه طاقمها
ترصد تنفيذ غارات جويه
على عدد من مواقع القوات الروسيه
وتحصيناتها في محيط باخمه
في محاوله لوقف تقدمها فالمروحيات تلعب
دورا مهما بالنسبه للجانب الاوكراني تناور
المروحيات بحذر شديد
فبعد كل ضربه تطلق القنابل الحراريه
لتقياها من الاستهداف بالصواريخ الروسيه
المضاده للطائرات ولتجنب مصير طائرات
اسقطت خلال المعارك بعد اتمام المهمه تعود
المروحيات الى منطقه اكثر امنا نسبيا تهبط
احداها هنا لتقلنا نحو احد مواقعها الخاصه
[موسيقى]
هذه نتوجه نحو قاعده جويه مع فريق القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه للتعرف على عملهم عن
قرب
يحرص طاقم الطائره المؤلف من قائد ومساعد
ومهندس على اجراء مناورات مستمره اثناء
التحليق والبقاء على ارتفاع منخفض لا يزيد
عن 30 مترا لتجنب رصدها
نهبط في القاعده المستحدثه بعيدا عن
الانظار حيث يتمركز سرب من الطائرات
المروحيه المختلفه وتتم عمليات الصيانه
لطائرات باتت متقدمه في العمر
بعد كل غاره وقبل كل مهمه نقوم بالتحقق من
سلامه المروحيه وصيانتها بشكل فوري فهذه
الطائرات تحتاج لعنايه دائمه يتم تزويد
المروحيات بصواريخ جديده حيث تحمل 20 منها
في كل جانب ويكتب الجنود على بعضها رسائل
لاعدائهم
يوري صديقي قتل خلال المعارك ولا شيء يعوض
خسارته لكنني اتذكره بكتابه اسمه على هذه
الصواريخ التي سنضرب بها قتلته
قبيل انطلاقه نحو مهمته القادمه يحدثنا
ايفان احد الطيارين الشبان ذو الثلاثين
عاما عن طبيعه عملياتهم واحتياجاتهم
ننفذ غارات مزدوجه بمروحيتين على الخط
الامامي لقوات العدو لاسناد القوات
الارضيه طورنا طائره اللوجستيه كهذه
للهجمات لكنها قديمه وقدراتها محدوده امام
امكانات العدو الجويه ونحتاج لطائرات
حديثه
وهكذا تكتمل الاستعدادات لتنفيذ مزيد من
الهجمات
نحو مهمه جديده قد تكون الاخيره بالنسبه
لهم تنطلق هذه المروحيات التابعه للقوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه في ظروف استثنائيه
شديده الخطوره لكن الاوكرانيين يرون ان
اهميتها بالنسبه لمعاركهم
تستحق المخاطره حسن مسعود الجزيره من احدى
قواعد القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه السريه
شرقيه اوكرانيا